le premier succès le tour de france je
vais parler de ça direct parce que alors
que tous les événements sportifs majeurs
comme l'euro de football les jeux
olympiques ont été annulés à cause du
coronavirus il ya une compétition qui va
avoir lieu c'est le tour de france
christian prudhomme le directeur de
l'épreuve était invité au 13 heures de
france 2 et il a officialisé les
nouvelles dates du tout le français et
lui dire si vous trouvez que c'est une
bonne idée ou une mauvaise idée
et moi je vais proposer quelque chose ce
que la sémec si le tour de france a lieu
on va pouvoir faire d'autres
compétitions sportives
et puis je me demandais ce qu'il a
demandé aux autorités ou pas du tout
regardez la vidéo de france de regarder
ce qu'il a dit le patron du tour de
france nouvelles dates du tour de france
seront depuis quelques minutes c'est
officiel du samedi 29 août au dimanche
20 septembre sur le parcours tel qu'il
était prévu puisque j'ai eu au téléphone
hier 49 élus du parcours du tour de
france et que tous et toutes m'ont dit
oui nous serons là nous travaillons
depuis plusieurs semaines avec les
services de l'état bien évidemment en
lien aussi avec les familles du cyclisme
la ligue nationale de cyclisme
la fédération internationale du cio et
donc je vous confirme en effet que le
tour on a mieux deux mois plus tard qu'à
l'ordinaire gilles n'a jamais lieu aussi
tard lui aussi tard dans l'histoire mais
il se déroulera du 29 août au 20
septembre
ok alors voilà donc le tour se déroulera
du 27 juin au 19 juillet mais j'ai pas
compris non alors il devait se dérouler
du 27 du 6 au 7 juin 19 juillet va se
dérouler du 29 août au 20 septembre est
juste les cherry hill a demandé aux
autorités au me souviens de ton 906 font
les font leur lit tout seul les mecs moi
j'ai envie de prendre mon vélo là cinq
ans à nocolas rico ce confinement la
coved il ne faut pas commis 19
on va rentrer non mais franchement les
mecs
alors je pose la question aux
téléspectateurs sur twitter est ce que
vous comprenez que le tour de france ait
lieu voilà comme ça alors il balance un
truc alors dans ce cas là pourquoi pas
roland garros aux siens on peut faire
roland garros epareca une idée que m'a
dit loïc qui est mon ami bien sûr mon
bras droit
il m'a dit peut-être en garde aussi se
pose la question de faire roland garros
avec un siège sur deux voilà deux
voilà un téléspectateur sur deux jean
michel maire alors le problème tour de
france avec tous les autres sports tous
les autres sports peuvent se joue à
faire on les jolies bof
tous les autres corps tous les autres
soit faire plus de sport peuvent se
faire en été ou en hiver le tour de
france le vélo c'est en était enfin être
quand il fait beau
donc ne peuvent pas faire ils ont taillé
de cloud donc songer de le faire dans
une carriole qui est limité entre mai et
octobre donc ici même pas l'annuler une
somme jugée deux semaines dans ce credo
et c'est vrai que c'est compliqué ouais
non mais oui alors mais jean michel
lemaire sans rigoler il a une tête
aujourd'hui avec sa chemise bleue on
dira commentateur du tour de france 2
france 2 c'est sans déconner moi j'ai
raté un carton que j'adore et que je à
qui je fais un gros bisou c'est pas très
content elle voilà c'est il est il
exceptionnel et ça un amour de mecs je
voulais le dire et je lui fais un gros
gros bisous à patrick si nous regarde
matthieu delormeau question pendant du
tour de france moi je trouve que c'est
très choquant c'est vraiment une honte
parce qu'on pourra faire tous les sports
actuellement 100 spectateurs on pourrait
faire roland garros à huis clos on
pourrait faire la formule 1 100
spectateurs au castellet rond pourraient
tous deux bien sûr c'est juste qu'on
aimerait voir montrer voilà la semaine
dernière j'ai faim thomas king kong tout
seul contre le mur permis qu il y avait
personne
on est en train de montrer aux gens de
demander aux gens de faire un effort
incroyable
il faut que tout le monde le fast food
les sportifs très riche pour une vie
aussi eux aussi devraient mettre leur
carrière entre parenthèses pour montrer
l'exemple
pourquoi eux peuvent aller faire leur
métier et s'éclater sur la route et nous
on veut pas perdre le nôtre
dochia membre je pense qu'il faut tous
qu'on soit solidaires il n'y a pas de
raison que le tour de france fonctionne